my friend challenged me to learn how to
ride the unicycle in one day all based
off of a video I did not too long ago
where I learned how to do a kickflip and
the day a lot of people take issue with
learning but I did a kickflip in one day
I found a unicycle I need to find
someone who actually knows how to ride
it so I saw degrade my elementary school
decided to buy a bunch of unicycle and I
was obsessed do you think you could show
me how to do it I just pulled my piece
my doctor stopped me do any activities
unfortunately I cannot show come on come
on and I got some waivers that you need
to sign great I will absolutely do that
can you show us how to ride a unicycle
because we a just got dental surgery and
her doctor said no unicycling when
you're riding a bicycle it's more I
guess of keeping balance on your side to
side you know when you're on unicycle
it's more about front to back just like
this is gonna be your balance point
instead of this it swings up and then
you put your foot on does that sound
right yes just push it okay all right
here we go first try if I can do three
turns of the wheel without holding on
anything I've met my goal
I regret taking this video just drop him
along that pole and like just swim I
think it's like you can't try you know
you have to like I started by holding on
to something when I first started yeah
just start also maybe put something here
and your goal it's just like to get a
feel that's what I did
alright you don't need a helmet before
you crack your head
all right
[Music]
dan this is hot all right do I need a
shoulder okay okay and go for it
okay okay oh let's take a left let's
take a left take a left
okay I want to be able to get balance
and once I have that I'll let you know
yeah good luck all I need to do now is
work on my balance that mean I sit have
a nice sit
okay I'm gonna pop forward commence pump
all right you got bounce pump throw up
pump it Pump It
[Music]
not bad
that was my first rotation going forward
I'm getting used to the wave yeah hold
it hold it
okay you know you just can't think it's
just like get up and put your frickin
foot on the thing and now pedal let me
see if I can just circle around the
chair okay okay all right tell you left
foot
do not fall all right chair one pump bam
pump it again this is like what's the
quick way yep yep oh we're getting it
now
[Music]
if you're that devil or so close yeah
[Music]
let's get coffee
any progress for food
[Music]
thank you another chair in a distance
and like make a go like yeah yeah yeah
so like if you can go from here to here
you got it I think you can just hop on
that and when you start going yeah go
let me show you how far I've gotten okay
so this is pretty much it that looks
like it would be harder than actually
writing I'll just tell you what my
wrists really hurt I'll have you
watching an attempt yeah yeah right yeah
put your whole ass on it yeah bye see ya
you're still leaning back a little too
much yeah if you start with it at the
side like this like a level yeah even
then you bring your feet up and Oh Dan
dude your special bar is like glowing yo
base-jumping god he gave me some great
advice on weight distribution my knees
my shins hurt I've been on bang the hell
this isn't even look as cool as a
kickflip
I'm never gonna get this sucked
[Music]
yeah
all right here we go we're in sacrifice
mode now the clock is ticking today I
really haven't made much progress I
think this is what we are gonna do the
goal now is to just go full steam into
that
[Music]
come on you see this is straight-up
unicycling state
let's go home yeah I can't do it I
really can't do it this is really too
hard
[Music]
[Music]
want to quit is it's too hard
[Music]
I'm never gonna get to three let's go
[Music]
[Music]
the show created and now it's the
footage we'll see how what they think I
[Music]
did it
well I did a version of it you know do
it again for us yeah yeah all right all
right you know it I did it once
okay
[Music]